[Music]
hi everybody like you said I'm Andrew
from tonic
I'm CTO tonic and tonic we make a
platform for creating generative models
so unsurprisingly I'm talking about
generative models and how to make
friends with generative models in
particular how you can make synthetic
data for your sales needs for your data
science needs your development needs and
your testing needs so let's get going to
set the stage I want to talk about how I
came to this problem and it began in the
2009 financial crisis remember this when
yeah everything went to [ __ ] that's
where it begins and my former employer
Palantir was hired by a bank to help
them with a recommendation engine for
real estate pricing what was going on is
the banks had these call centers that
they had set up to help unload all of
the properties they were now in
ownership of because when your default
on your mortgage bank gets your property
right so they had all these properties
and they need to get rid of them and
they set up these call centers to do it
turns out people at call centers not
great negotiators when it comes to real
estate and so Palantir was was asked to
help create a tool that would give
recommendations to these call center
people so call would come in I want to
pay five thousand dollars for that house
put into the model the model would say
no the house is worth a hundred thousand
dollars got to say no to that
counteroffer or it would say great take
the offer it's a crap home and and so we
did this and it was a great success but
during the development of this project
we hit a snag that was really persistent
and a constant problem which was our
devs didn't have access to the data that
they needed in this case you know the
data was really sensitive data about
homes and mortgages and all that so like
if you've ever applied for a mortgage
you know you give them everything about
you including you know your your credit
score your income other personal details
and also included like the
current negotiations that were going on
about the mortgages so this data could
not leave the bank but the way Palantir
is set up all the development was
happening in Palo Alto and the
developers were not able to reproduce
bugs they weren't anticipating issues
scale testing was like not a thing it
was a problem so myself and a few other
engineers decided you know what we're
gonna do let's make a generative model
that will create a sufficiently accurate
data set to the real data that we can do
this testing and hopefully we can do it
all on site and catch a lot more bugs so
we did that and the developers work
happy they said great thanks this is
awesome now I now I have now I won't
give you as many bugs I was like yeah
thanks a lot but something else happened
that I didn't expect something I didn't
foresee and that was other people got in
the game the designers were like hey we
want this data too and the designers
were able to make more realistic or more
correct UIs for the data that they were
actually seen if you've ever seen this
problem of like designing with wrong
data or with incorrect data you end up
with designs that don't really fit the
needs of course the business people the
sales people got super excited because
now they could demo Palantir products on
this synthetic data set and we're able
to show banks like hey you have a
problem where you've got real estate
that you need better pricing on we have
a solution and they could show it with
real data in short everyone got super
jazzed about this stuff everyone was in
for the in for the ride they wanted the
synthetic data and you know QA people
scale testing the whole nine yards and
the experience made me realize something
which is we were starved for good data
at Palantir and we were chronically
under onic chronically under valuing how
you know how important it is to have
good test data you know just to give a
sense on the ROI here like it was me and
one other guy basically that for two
weeks jammed on this synthetic data a
synthetic data thing and that turned
into a data set that was used by
hundreds of engineers over the course of
many years so that's pretty good ROI
right like a couple guys a couple weeks
then lots of people using it
and you may have seen this too you know
you probably work in a project at some
point that had this data set and the
data set was like the data set and the
product comes and goes the features come
and goes refactored now we use go know
when user lying now but the data set
remains because it's the only data set
you got and you and you need to make you
know you need to make everything around
it so the conclusion of this is that
there is an opportunity I realized here
for people who understand data data folk
let's say to enable other parts of their
organization and if you're here and
you're not a data folk the opportunity
is you for to tell a data folk person
hey you can make my life better so I'm
here to tell you you can make lives
better by by doing this kind of thing
great so every talk needs a framework
this framework is a framework for making
friends and step1 and the framework is
to identify situations where data
deficiency occur this isn't about your
data problems necessarily it's about
looking outside and seeing like where
our data deficiencies in my organization
and and you know where our quick wins
that I can get creating some data set
step two is target the right kinds of
data sets and the last thing is not
really a step but anyway you can't
really mix double-u ELLs and endo Wells
the last one is toolbox for simple
modeling techniques and so we're going
to go through that's the framework of
the talk as well and we'll go through
these things one at a time and we'll
start with identifying situations where
data deficiencies occur okay so first
one I want to talk about is boundaries
boundaries exist in organizations at all
sorts of levels and this is like maybe
the lowest level of them so this is the
boundary of environments so we've got
staging and prod right and you can't put
the prod data in staging maybe you can
at your company but let me assure you
there are companies where you cannot do
this like imagine you're a bank once
again thanks prominent feature I guess
in my life they you know there might be
making an iOS app for checking your
checking account right and obviously you
can't use real people's data when you're
like testing that like oh look at that
that guy's a deadbeat or whatever like
can't do that
so so that's one boundary you can look
for boundaries and environments another
kind of boundary you can look for going
kind of up the level on the stack is
bounded between teams some teams will
have more access to data than others so
support might have access and they're
like look at this bud the guy found the
bug and then devs like well we don't
have access to that data so what do we
do another kind of boundary is between
companies so you might have an in-house
engineering team that has access to more
data than the outsourced engineering
team another example of this company
kind of dichotomy is between your
salespeople and your customers right so
what are your salespeople
what would your salespeople love to be
able to do they'd love to be able to
demo on your customers data like I
imagine you know you're building the
next Salesforce like Salesforce killer
3.0 and wouldn't be great to show you
know this potential customer deal flow
in your tool they would be super jazzed
and they'd be able to like you know
understand how your tool is gonna make a
big business and a big difference in
their business but of course no one's
going to give you your give you the data
just to give a demo so what's the next
best thing
synthetic data on your current customers
right take your current customers data
making some that a copy of that and now
you can give a demo that speaks to
speaks to the needs of your custom of
your potential customers the last
boundary I want to talk about is the
boundary between countries right there
is these laws now data localization or
data sovereignty laws that prevent data
from Crossing country boundaries for
example did you know if you have
personal data about a Russian it should
be in Russia that's a thing the Russians
don't want American Americans holding
their data of course if you're American
you just put it on Facebook and so
everything's cool right great so those
are boundaries different ways that you
can find yeah boundaries in your
organization that might have might
create data deficiencies the next thing
I want to talk about is regulatory so a
bunch of these you probably know about
HIPAA for healthcare GDP are for for
everything FERPA for education data
there's a CCPA you may have heard about
that a little bit that's the California
call it the Californian gdpr and it was
passed in 2018 but it doesn't come into
effect until 2020 and the like the
ramifications of this thing are somewhat
unknown at this point because there's a
lot like still up for interpretation but
I will say this it's gonna affect a lot
more companies in GDP are because well
first off it's affecting companies that
are in California are people that are
companies that collect data about
Californians and the bar is really low
like for all these things there's
regulations about like when it hits you
know for GDP are for CCPA
but the bar is really low you have
50,000 customers you're a hit by CCPA
so that's a thing that's coming up that
might impact your business and give you
an opportunity to be a data hero and
make some synthetic data and this thing
this way right the last the last kind of
boundary spot is certifications if
you've ever gone through a certification
process you know that there are sub
positions in the in these certifications
about what you can do with data ISO C
star sock all these things also if
you're going to be a pain in the ass
pick blue as your as your uh as your
icon color it's just very soothing you
know it's like FERPA everything's cool
great so those are three wait places you
can identify data deficiencies right
boundaries regulations that are coming
up and certifications great so now
imagine yourself thinking yourself great
I've gotten this far I've I've
identified a boundary that I want to
attack so what kind of data sets in that
boundary are going to be really ripe for
for using data synthesis on so I'm going
to argue for structured data being the
beginning of where you start with that
and I'll give some more examples in a
bit but you know there just to give a
non example of structure data things
like image synthesis super hard probably
not where you're going to start doing
this at your company the structured data
is a good start and I'll give some
examples using
the mortgage example that I started this
with right okay so we have a home what
kind of data do you have on a home well
to start with you're gonna have like
continuous data data on like the size
and square feet or the date it was built
his time also continuous not a flat
circle
anyone know Matthew McConaughey yeah
true detective
it's great anyway so time is continuous
and and we also got categorical data
like the style of the roof or is it a
fancy home with a pool we also have
relational data so this is like how this
property relates to other entities in
the database for example the private
home might have an agent and an owner
knows our address or you know provided
in foreign keys another kind of data is
event data an event date is super
interesting because it happens at a
different cardinality to the to the
underline you know to the property data
right there's a lot of events for a
single home and you know they happen
also in like a certain order often
you'll have like an appraisal and then
it will sell but not always sometimes
right so that can make events pretty
interesting too to synthesize I wrote a
blog post about it I can tell you about
it later and then we got text data which
is like notes appraisal notes offers
that kind of thing and demographic data
so address city state that kind of thing
so let's organize these we've got
statistical so that's going to be the
things there like some simple
statistical models continuous data
categorical data demographic data we've
got structural so these affect like the
shape of your data how things are
related what the cardinality of
different sets are going to be so those
are your events and your relational
we've got text oh yeah sorry
yeah text and we'll go to the next light
which looks more like the first one so
now now let's talk about how we're gonna
model these and my purpose in this
section of the talk is to give you guys
kind of like a small toolbox of things
you can dip into when you're addressing
this issue it's not going to be like the
whole set of covering all possible
situations but I hopefully picked a
couple interesting ones here to give you
an idea of what to do and I can't go
through every one because we don't have
enough time but there's questions at the
end and also there will be office hours
next door which I'm happy to entertain
all sorts of questions stories whatever
great so let's start getting into it and
the first one I'm going to do is
actually kind of fake I'm gonna talk
about the identity model the identity
model is when you just use the data
that's already in the database and I
feel like it's important to bring this
one up because if you approach every
data synthesis problem with I'm going to
simulate all the data you are in for a
long haul and there really isn't a need
often to do such an extreme approach
right frequently you can get away with
taking just a few columns that are
really sensitive or a few tables that
are sensitive and then keeping the rest
the same you know it's blindingly
obvious but I wanted to make sure you
guys were we're aware of this
possibility before you go knee-deep so
the first one I want to talk about
that's kind of more real is for
continuous data and that one is the
approach that I'm going to espouse here
is kernel density estimation kernel
density estimation is a way of modeling
continuous variables it's a called a
nonparametric method which means that
you don't need to specify the
distribution upfront so you don't need
to say oh it's Gaussian or it's gonna be
exponentially distributed it'll figure
that out for you kind of not really but
close enough and also it's really easy
to extend in multiple dimensions and
most importantly it's really easy to
implement so that'll make it very
attractive for our use case right of we
don't know what kind of data there is in
there we don't to think too hard let's
just do something that'll be easy so how
does it work
suppose you have a distribution like
this one right here I've got a PDF on
the screen and it's not Gaussian or
exponential or anything like that is
some funky shape and we've got empirical
data that fits this distribution so it
might look a little bit like this
hopefully you can see those hashes on
the x-axis right there and you notice
that the hashes are more frequent where
there are peaks in the PDF because
that's where we're higher like
of sampling right the way kernel density
estimation works is it begins with a
kernel a kernel is a small function with
certain properties one of notably one is
that it kind of has like a finite
support not technically entirely true
but sort of finite support in the sense
that like it did there's off to zero or
asymptotes to zero as it goes out and
the way kernel density estimation works
is it begins by putting one of these
little kernels on these little functions
on top of every one of your empirical
data points and then the final solution
is to just sum up all of the kernels and
now you have a probability to serve a
distribution function that kind of looks
like the original one right now
it happens to be that if you knew what
the distribution was up front let's say
you knew it was gone for whatever reason
you should use Gaussian it'll be better
but if you don't know and you just don't
want to check this will get you pretty
close certainly close enough and a few
more details about kernel density
estimation first off you know you might
be wondering well what should I use for
my kernel a really great choice is the
normal distribution but there are plenty
of other choices out there you can go on
Wikipedia and read about them or
download open source libraries and learn
about them that way so normal
distribution is great kernel for K
dimensions you can use a k-dimensional
kernel a k-dimensional kernel simply
means you know in the Gaussian case it's
like multi-dimensional Gaussian also
easy to implement and then to sample
from a KDE all you need to do is pick a
random kernel so pick one of those
random functions and then sample
randomly from that kernel and that's
actually you know really manageable in
terms of implementation right and you
can of course download open source
libraries that will do this for you
there is one parameter to kernel density
estimation despite it being called
nonparametric and that is the kernel
width so it's like how why do I want to
make this function right and and there
are techniques for getting a good value
for that it's important that you get a
good value for that otherwise you won't
converge to the to the underlying thing
I once again read about those on
Wikipedia or download an open source
library that'll just do that for you
great
so that's kernel density estimation the
next thing I want to talk about is how
to do relational which I think it's kind
of interesting like how do you preserve
the shape of these data sets when you're
synthesizing so let's take an example
from our home our home mortgage you know
example we've got agents and properties
and you'll notice that the red agent is
really popular on the homes right that
guy covers a lot of homes and then we've
got the the green agent which just has a
few homes and then the blue one which
has some medium amount of homes right
and if you were to graph this on a bar
chart it might look something like this
where the x-axis each one of those is an
agent that has some number of properties
right and so you might be wondering like
okay like why why would I want to
synthesize this and what do I mean by
that okay so what I mean by that is in
this properties table there's gonna be
an agent ID column right and we need to
create synthetic values for that agent
ID column and you might want to do that
because you might want to change for
example the size of agents so you might
want to simulate a situation where you
have more agents than you used to have
for scale testing let's say and if
you're gonna do that then you'll need to
redistribute the properties among these
new set of agents in such a way that
preserves the original distributional
intent of the of the you know original
data right okay so let's talk about how
we're gonna do that and I'm gonna use
words to describe it
right now and the words may or may not
make sense to you and then after that
I'm gonna show some pictures and
hopefully it'll make sense so here are
the words that may or may not make sense
to you the way we're gonna do it is we
are going to create a PDF that
approximates this bar chart then we will
calculate a CDF from it cumulative
cumulative density function and then we
will invert the CDF to sample agent ID
from that so let's do some pictures now
and some equations but ignore the
equation for the house
so the first step we're going to do is
approximate the underlying data with a
continuous function so all I've done
here is connect the dots as it were and
made a bunch of linear approximations to
the underlying data and so this equation
that you can largely ignore I am
including it here in case someone wants
to go back and look at the slide and be
like well how do you actually do it
that's where you start and this is
simply a linear approximation oh yeah so
simply drawing the line between the dots
it's a linear a linear spline I guess
would be the right term for it okay so
you start with this continuous function
and I've also remapped the domain from
agents like each bucket is an agent to a
zero to one scale right next thing I do
create a PDF out of that really easy to
create a PDF all you need to do is
divide by the integral of the original
original function which is to say you're
just normalizing it okay this is the
important property of a PDF is that it
integrates to 1 so I'm normalizing it to
make G of X now f of X integrate to 1
then next step remember I said the words
next step was to create a cumulative
density function so I'm going to create
a cumulative density function of f of X
by integrating f of X yeah that's right
and then I'm going to invert it and by
that I mean I'm gonna take a random
value a uniform random value from 0 to 1
computers are great well arguably great
at making uniform random values between
0 and 1 and I can take that and I can
invert it by basically going from y-axis
to x-axis to create an agent ID and
technically speaking that equation is
slightly wrong it should be the floor of
F inverse R times n agents ok so that's
how that that's the picture version of
the words I have two more pictures that
will hopefully make it really all make
sense great
these pictures are top quality I know so
here was our cumulative density function
right why does it work that when I do
this why is it that from there I can get
a distribution that looks like the
original data set well here's the reason
here's the rationale the CDF is super
steep at the beginning right the reason
why it's super steep is because it
underlined what it is representing is
the is the number of properties that
agents have in it according to the you
know wherever you are on the x-axis so
in the beginning agents have lots of
properties so the CDF goes up really
fast ok what that
means is when I invert things so when I
invert values between zero and one that
are uniformly distributed like 80
percent of that is going to the first 20
percent of agents so that's how I've
created a situation where a bunch of
agents are getting a lot of properties
and then some agents are getting fewer
properties hopefully that all made sense
otherwise ask a question at the end I
have no more pictures on this oh how do
I do so I just want to give an example
of when I did this you know how we use
this in atonic where I work right now
where we make generative models for a
living so we had a customer that had a
dataset that looks somewhat similar to
this and and what they wanted to do was
do some scale testing to imagine what it
would look like when they had more sales
more customers more products on sale so
they asked us to do something like this
10x our sales 5x our customers to X our
products while keeping everything else
the same and the technique I just
described is exactly how we did it right
so this is this is how you can like real
world use of putting this stuff into
practice cool I've got one more modeling
technique that I kind of want to talk
about and that's for text so text I
started this whole section by saying you
should do structured data and I'm going
to talk about text what's that about
well turns out text shows up a lot and
depends on depending on what you want to
do with it there are some simple tricks
that you can do that make text synthesis
like blindingly easy or really really
hard it just really depends on your goal
though right if your goal is I want to
give designers a good sense for what
text laid out in our product generated
by our users right like they're making
BIOS or comments or likes or whatever it
is they're making I want to give
designers a really good sense of how
that's gonna look and feel on you know
when they're when when they're doing
design that's a totally different
ballgame then I want to train a model on
you know sentiment analysis according to
the comments that people make so this is
more focused on that for more use case
of like I want my designers to be able
to do good designs and my testers to be
able to go do tests and developers to
make good code so let's talk about it
for a second
suppose we have this wonderful blob of
text it is
a let's say a medical note write about
Jane little and often like though you
know what would you do if I said oh I've
got this and I want to make some fake
data for it I tell you what I do I'll
use lorem ipsum right everyone uses
Laura Maps um don't use lorem ipsum it's
really really terrible look at this look
at these two look how much data has been
lost in this transition I mean there's
basically no data left at all
if you're a designer you might not
realize that hey people use bulleted
lists here right the bulleted lists down
here and there's like kind of a heading
at the top that might be kind of useful
to make it pop out or whatever so let's
talk about some improvements we can do
the first improvement really simple one
don't use lorem ipsum just replace all
the letters with other letters random
ones keep the capitalization replace all
the numbers whether random numbers and
keep the punctuation new lines and all
that jazz the same and now you've got
another data set that works really well
for doing design stuff right I mean you
can compare the two it looks a lot more
similar right the problem with this data
set depending on your security goals
would be that you know especially like
in medical data you might have a really
rare disease that has a super long name
and now you can find everyone who has
that rare disease because it's a unique
length of characters in the original
data set right so an alternative to this
if you're you know your constraints are
a little more rigid is format preserving
lorem ipsum bring warm epsom back unless
you format preserving warm Epsom and I
made a little open-source version of
this as well in case people want to use
format preserving lorem ipsum it's like
all of 20 lines of code you can
literally copy it from the Python that I
have to any language you want it's not
very complicated but it's cool and it
like makes data that you know is more
secure and also you know gives the
designers what they need to make smart
decisions right cool so that's kind of
the conclusion I'm gonna have for the
modeling section actually maybe I'll say
one more thing about this you might be
also wondering okay well great how do I
make a generative model out of this
I want to make is like this is great for
masking but how do I make a generative
model out of this well one simple
technique is to grab like a hundred
thousand values from your data set and
then use those as a seed like a scaffold
for creating things like this or things
like this right so so then you end up
generating you can generate as much as
you want or as little as you want and
yeah and so that's how you create your
generative model okay so we talked about
one from each kind of column which was
intentional and but that's all we have
time for for for this session like I
said you go to my office hours if you
have more questions about other stuff
here with that I will give a framework
wrap up so step one identify data
deficiency and so that's looking for
boundaries in your organization right at
all different levels your organization
looking for places where certifications
might be happening you know are
certifications that gonna happen or
regulations are hitting you target
structured data sets avoid the
unstructured ones because those can be a
whole other beast and have this toolbox
of simple modeling techniques and we
talked about relational data texts and
continuous data and with that I will
give some final takeaways teams are
often missing the data that they need to
be as efficient as they could be and
data scientists and data folk in general
have the knowledge and the skills to
actually help this so and it's easier
than you think
so you know if you're a data person that
can they can address this situation go
out there find boundaries and help
people out and you will make some
friends and with that I will take
questions my question is about the risk
of DN anima zation yes I can imagine
using this if I had access to the whole
model that using to generate new data
sets I could do something like rejection
sampling to find possible worlds that
match the data that I have to try to
invite you to so what do you think about
that is this yeah to that so a lot of a
lot of times the way I think about that
is
it really depends on your goals for the
data right if your goal is to do like
the next Netflix challenge and put your
data out there for everyone to see
bar is really really really high as it
turns out because there are a lot of
people with free time on their hand that
will DM atomize this data if they can on
the other hand if your goal is like I
want my designers to be able to do a
better job designing some stuff then the
risk is just much so much lower you know
and so your profile for for the level of
security is just as lower as a result so
you know it's a big [ __ ] gnarly deep
topic that one can go down but that's
usually where I start it's like well
let's talk about your goals and then
we'll figure out what the right level of
synthesis is for you like how do you
typically handle null data or empty
string here you know particularly with
the relational model you were talking
about okay yeah interesting okay
so typically the way we you know now I'm
talking about like the way we do it what
we've done it for customers so far
hedonic is largely to try to recreate
whatever sort of null distribution there
might be in the original data set and so
that just means kind of measuring what
is the propensity for Nowell to be in a
given column or you know maybe even more
powerfully what is the propensity of an
OLE to be given other constraints in the
system and then recreate that by saying
okay well we're gonna put nulls in
according to that distribution so yeah
nulls are super important and if there
are in the existing data the goal of all
this right is to create data that looks
like the original data and that includes
all the warts even if you're like some
engineer is like you know this data
should never be null if there is an if
there is not a not null constraint in
your database I guarantee you there will
be values that are no everything exists
in data and and so yeah it's really
important to be able to you know keep
that keep those constraints sorry not
the constraints but keep the keep that
original data in your synthetic data
this seems incredibly cool for a like
design engineering use case but if I'm
using this for something like a sales
demo yeah then it would seem really
problematic that like there's an
real way here to model like covariances
between the stuff like there's no way to
embed like if I'm demoing a product
that's a data product and I want to show
an insight you would find in this thing
mm-hmm that seems like something that is
gonna be hard for me to transmit into a
synthetic data set if it requires more
than an individual column so yeah yeah
yeah yeah no I got you so with the KDE
example I kind of neglected to mention
this every time I write notes about what
I'm gonna say and then I just say stuff
so I I forgot to say this thank you for
bringing it up so you know one of the
things I talked about was you can do
multi-dimensional KDE why did I even say
that the reason why you can do reason
why that's useful is multi-dimensional
KDE is joint probabilities right so what
that's saying is I want to do a joint
probability across these three different
variables and or four variables or
whatever I mean don't do too many
because then your data is not going to
be so good but certainly one two three
that works well and that you can capture
exactly what you're bringing up right
like an example would be of course the
the value of a house and the number of
the size of the house square foot versus
price those are going to be related and
and so yeah you can do it do it the
answer to your question is you better do
it when you're making synthetic data
include those correlations that's that's
an important part of it because
otherwise you won't be able to do those
sort of sales demos and those
investigations other questions I know
there are other people with raised hands
do you have experience with synthesizing
like geographical data sets and so like
for instance if somebody wanted to
replicate like sales data or something
like that yeah what are the techniques
yeah if there's time I'm also interested
in like the time dimension as well it's
time to mention so yeah demographics was
one of the topics that I had as a thing
that I didn't reach so that's like city
state names that kind of thing
there are a couple of cool datasets out
there that you can use as starting
points it depends on exactly what you
want to do like I said for the other
question right it's like it depends on
exactly what you want to do but there
are interesting data sets that you can
get out there like there's one on
basically every address in basically
every major metropolis Rapala intern
area in the world and then you can cross
that with population data and then you
can sample from geographic locations
according to population and use real
addresses of course they're they're real
but they're also fake because they're
like that person doesn't exist or if
you're worried about using like a really
real address take a real address and
then make it not real by using a fake
street name or something like that those
are kind of things that not to plug my
company too much but that's the kind of
thing that you get photonic for free
well after paying us with the product so
yeah that's the kind of that but that's
a totally valid question and and you can
use like there's open source data sets
that can make that good if you want to
talk about more during office hours
that'd be cool too so
is there is there any way of starting
off with without any supervision so you
just give it let's say a data set and
perhaps a set of queries that are being
executed on that data set
hmm and it figures out which attributes
a category or column which attributes
are relational and starts from there
there are certainly yeah there are
certainly approaches to to anonymizing
data that are different than this one
right
for example differential privacy I don't
know if you've heard of that one but
that that's one of their approaches
right is like let's look at the let's
look at the shape of the queries that
we're getting and the data and see what
we can do to anonymize that data and
then if your query is too specific we
just say no or you ask too many queries
we just say no because eventually if you
ask so many queries you might eventually
figure out you know something underlying
about the data so there are definitely
approaches to that that's you know not
the approach that I'm a spouse in here
and I'm not saying that one is worse or
better than the other they're just
different approaches you could use the
existing corpus queries to generate the
stuff that apparently
languages I guess annotate as a category
right yeah yeah definitely
[Music]